you said tea party earlier was it like
the whole michelle bachmann era yeah
that area i wasn't a huge bachmann fan
i came in you'll hate this probably i
could just tell i just can read people
because i no i no no i guarantee it but
i came in being like a sarah palin fan
um and the reason i was a sarah fan
now i know sarah so i know a little bit
about her no i just see i see you as
someone who probably i don't think she'd
be your first choice let's just say that
but you know what not only me 99 of
america yeah but you know there's a
reason for that because you've been told
what you've been told about sarah palin
and most of it's not true but regardless
i got interested in sarah palin i'll
tell you why because
first of all she just kind of showed up
out of nowhere but i saw that mccain
plucked her out of nowhere because she
wasn't going to be rushed from her house
she never said that i wasn't um i wasn't
a mccain
fan look at us having the view
battling it out never said that but um
not that way anyway but yeah i wasn't a
mccain fan but i was like who's this
woman and the only reason she was
interesting to me was because media
couldn't stand her from second one and
the take i saw the takedown and i said
okay let me figure out maybe she's
terrible so i did a bunch of research on
her work in alaska
as mayor and as governor and i was like
okay she's actually quite legit and this
is why they hate her and she's also very
personable and
so i became kind of um interested in
what she brought to the table
um and she also was a soccer mom she she
felt like a regular person to me which i
really liked because i was a regular
person in a business where everyone felt
like you needed some degree i don't have
a journalism degree thankfully i didn't
waste my time doing that but um so
colombia wasn't journalism colombia was
spanish literature spanish literature
that's why you taught that for many
years yeah so we after you met you know
how sometimes you're like oh my gosh
she's so amazing and then after you meet
sarah was what you read and what you saw
the same as the time you spent with
sarah
sarah's just a regular person she's just
a mom she is
a well-intentioned political figure she
makes mistakes she's not always the most
articulate in expressing her ideas all
the time as as neither am i neither is
anyone else it's hard to be in the
spotlight sometimes
she's um she has a great record in
alaska i know they destroyed her once
she went back um a lot of oppo research
i mean the media landed in alaska they
were like we're going to land there
we're going to figure out what's wrong
with her they were reading her emails
line by line by line which is
interesting they had no interest in
hillary clinton's emails but
where she lied repeatedly but can you
imagine like you're being told you're
going to be working out of alaska here's
where you're going that's your job
my question to you on palin is i
actually completely understand why
regular girls soccer mom totally get
that
as far as vice president united states
do you think she was a little over her
in a little over her head
no i think she had a really horrible
team around her um
that didn't really support her and i
don't think she really understood i
think she understood establishment
politics in alaska governor of alaska
yeah and she wasn't like a little small
city mayor pete butterjudge you know
south bend indiana that's true and peter
judge has been glorified for that
limited record that he has that he did
fix a lot of potholes so let's have a
little respect there you go took two
months off pat was good
though because think about the way
those two people were viewed one was
glorified and covers of magazines and
one was like oh she's not up to the job
she knew a lot about the establishment
in alaska because she was dealing with
the murkowskis and all that but i don't
know that she was prepared for the
national stage and what that was going
to look like i think that was her team
or the mccain i think it was mccain
no i knew her team meg stapleton and all
them but no she yeah but regardless
whether you love her a hater i mean she
was demonized from day the woman didn't
have a chance but just think about
anybody that's announced as a vp go any
go go and go think about what vp people
were like oh my gosh this is fantastic
even pence when they said pence did you
know pence
did you know governors
did you sit there and say that's the
right selection nobody's first pick was
pence nobody's second pick was pence
so mccain
you know like the whole conversation
with giuliani
what giuliani ran on in the first time
he ran for president if he would have
ran on that and that was today
giuliani's a president
if mayor giuliani ran so sometimes it's
also timing uh when you're the first
person that's going to come out as
you're the vp you're a woman you're
going out there
chances are you're probably set into
tone for the next person that's going to
go out there and win it's not you like
you know how you think about friendster
uh facebook before facebook was what
myspace before myspace was friendster
what happened to friends are you still
on friendster yeah i i sent you
what do you mean i foreign you all day
oh that might be a different pattern
david patrick so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]